de juillet à septembre 2022 vous avez
tenté une expérience je rappelle que les
saisies de moins de 1, 5 étaient classé
sans suite afin de diminuer la charge
pénale pouvez-vous dresser un rapide
bilan de cette action pouvez-vous nous
dire également si les contrôles s % et
les arrêtés préfectoraux antimul ont
réussi à perturber le trafic de
stupéfiants et enfin pensez-vous qu'un
scanner qui permett de relever les
objets ingérés à l'instar de chipol
permettra de porter un coup dur au
trafic et puis Président si si tu
permets euh je voudrais aussi poser une
question à monsieur le Président du
tribunal judiciaire monsieur Abbassi en
septembre 2022 le garde des saau Éric
Dupont mouréti avait annoncé l'envoi en
Guyane de brigade de renfort afin de
palier le manque d'effectif au tribunal
ces renforts vous ont-ils permis
d'améliorer le traitement judicière et
faut-il péréniser ses renforts il y a 2
ans également j'avais interpellé le
ministre de la Justice en QAG car
j'estimais et d'ailleurs je l'estime
toujours que la Guyane mérite de
disposer d'une je qui lui est propre
afin de mieux lutter contre le trafic de
stupéfiants euh je sais pas si je vous
oblige à sortir de votre réserve mais
j'aimerais bien connaître votre avis
pour répondre à la première question sur
la la la phase voouà la la fameuse
histoire du 1,5 qui avait
instrumentalisé par par par le par par
certains médias pas forcément très
bienveillants c'est effectivement une
phase exploratoire où dans des documents
internes on avait pourquoi 1,5 parce
qu'en fin de compte c'était la quantité
qu'on avait de façon traditionnelle
incorporée et qu'on avait décidé de
d'évaluer la avec le préfet de l'époque
la potentialité de de recourir donc de
façon beaucoup plus importante aux
arrêtés
administratifs plutôt qu'à exercer des
poursuites voilà donc le le le le
l'histoire de d'un,5 c'est éétait
uniquement ça il a jamais été question
de déjudiciariser quoi que ce soit en
matière de stupéfiant la preuve c'est
que DEP sur une année on a augmenté de
200 plus de 200 % vous le verrez dans ma
réponse écrite j'ai fait le calcul
quasiment 230 % le nombre de garde à vue
les 100 % mules donc cet outil
administratifs qui quand même vise à
empêcher une personne de se mettre en
danger euh puisqu'on l'empêche de de
monter dans un aéronef avec le risque
que les une de ces boulettes éclates
entraîn la mort
instantanément donc effectivement c'est
notre bouclier c'est-à-dire que c'est ce
qui permet euh et bien donc de de de
d'être à la hauteur de la stratégie de
nos adversaires de
saturation par un moyen qui est souple
et qui a permis de de bloquer
un certain nombre de gens depuis aller
depuis début novembre on a un
effondrement du nombre de mules alors il
y a pas de mul qui se dirige vers roissi
on essae actuellement d'essayer de
comprendre pourquoi euh et on a une
baisse très sensible des mules avec la
disparition de
filières on avait au départ des des
filières baltes qui ont complètement
disparu assez rapidement ces gens ont dû
seréartic sur d'autres itinéraires le
scanner alors honnêtement on a écarté
cette solution ici
euh d'une part en raison de ce que j'ai
évoqué tout à l'heure de la durée qui
nous a accordé pour contrôler les gens
un scanner c'est un acte médical en plus
donc il nous faut une structure médicale
ça prend beaucoup de temps on peut pas
passer même si on a deux vols qui son
qui sont étalés sur 4 He on peut pas
passer 5 ou 600 personne au scanner dans
la durée qui nous est impartie le
scanner euh il faut le mettre sur les
aéroports parisiens d'autant que donc
vous avez évoqué la question vous avez
eu nos collègues de fort- de- France le
mécanisme de contournement est en train
de de de de de se faire nous on a fait
deux essais de contrôle 100 % sur deux
vols fort- de- France sur 150 passagers
on avait 10 mules à chaque fois donc il
y a bien euh il y a bien des filières
qui essayent de de procéder à un
contournement alors pour répondre à la
question sur la geirs en définitive dans
la circulaire de de politique pénale que
j'ai que j'ai évoqué le gardessau avait
décidé de la création non pas d'une
geerss parce que là il faudrait je pense
modifier le code de l'organisation
judiciaire et le code de procédure
pénale parce qu'ils sont prévus dans des
textes mais de façon très pragmatique a
demandé à ce que soit créée une division
délinquance organisé ce qui est le cas
au sein de mon parquet puisque et
monsieur Alexandre roussle Magri est un
des un des des des trois magistrats de
cette division là on a euh depuis le
mois de septembre on avait même un peu
anticiper créer cette fameuse division
qui globalement a en tout cas au niveau
du parquet une activité identique à
celle à celle d'une à celle d'une JS
voilà il existe euh des dossiers des
affaires que nous traitons en
blanchiment hein de de trafic de
stupéfiant via l'infraction spécifique
qui est prévu par le Code de pénal euh à
deux niveaux le premier niveau c'est
celui bah des transporteuses et des
transporteurs de cocaïne qui reviennent
en guyan et qui souvent achètent des
biens de consommation
euh que ce soit des véhicules haut de
gamme et et et des et des des des
vêtements de luxe et des biens de
consommation des téléphones portables
assez cher et ce genre de bien euh les
services de de police et de gendarmerie
travaillent à tous les niveaux euh il y
a une capacité
d'enquête avec des moyens limités en
terme d'enquête mais il y a aussi une
nécessité de pouvoir juger ces personn
là et le le créneau d'audience si vous
me permettez l'expression au tribunal
judiciaire de Cayenne est extrêmement
cher monsieur le garde des saau avait
promis la création de brigad C brigades
ont bien été créées elles nous ont bien
été affecté selon les modalités
précisées par Madame Sigala mais il faut
savoir qu'on aura toujours un temps de
retard on sera toujours en décalage par
rapport à un accroissement de la
délinquence et euh la seule possibilité
véritablement d'aboutir à un résultat
qui soit un résultat adéquat
c'est-à-dire d'être en osmose avec ce
qu'appelait tout à l'heure Monsieur le
Procureur nos adversaires alors nous
pour nous on les considère comme des
justiciables point mais il faut
effectivement euh une véritable prise en
en compte et une sorte de euh de plan
Marshal